existen dos maneras para sacar de su
puesto a un presidente de eeuu el
impeachment o convocar la enmienda 25 el
congreso introdujo esta disposición de
la constitución en 1963 tras el
asesinato de john fitzgerald kennedy
ignacio con la clara intención de ser
utilizado cuando un presidente se
encontrará incapacitado física o
mentalmente pero la sección cuarta de la
enmienda 25 permite una aplicación más
amplia en caso de que el comandante en
jefe muestre el ser peligroso para
ocupar su puesto o rehúsa dimitir desde
el momento en que se invoca la enmienda
25 el presidente quedaría despojado de
sus poderes y el vicepresidente se
convertiría en el principal poder del
país para que esto ocurra mike pence y
la mayoría del gabinete de trampa
necesitarían presentar un escrito ante
el congreso declarando lo no apto para
su puesto
y el ataque del miércoles a nuestra
democracia tenía como objetivo
asustarnos para que no cumpliéramos con
nuestros deberes como representantes del
pueblo no dejaremos que tengan éxito
estamos comprometidos con nuestro
trabajo para el pueblo sin embargo
parece poco probable que ocurra una
destitución vía la enmienda 25 dado que
pensa ha sido un ferviente defensor de
trump durante su mandato pese al
distanciamiento de los últimos días
la alternativa demócrata pasaría por un
nuevo proceso de impeachment si bien la
falta de tiempo juega en su contra el
senado no se volverá a reunir hasta el
día 19 y no tienen asegurada la mayoría
de dos tercios necesaria para este
proceso si finalmente la vía de la
enmienda 25 no da resultado los
demócratas comenzarán el miércoles con
el proceso de impeachment